hello good afternoon and welcome we
start with some breaking news this hour
that the prime minister
and his wife carrie are expecting their
second baby
mr johnson made the announcement on an
instagram post also revealing that
she suffered a miscarriage earlier this
year well let's go straight now
to westminster into our political
correspondence rob powell
so rob good afternoon to you some happy
news but also some sad detail
in this announcement yeah carrie johnson
uh
the wife of the prime minister boris
johnson made this announcement this
afternoon
on her instagram account she posted a
picture but also some text
uh below it in which she said that she
was hoping for our rainbow baby
this christmas so a suggestion that this
um second child for the couple
uh will be due at the tail end um of
this year
uh but she also um as you said as you
say revealed some more somber details
um about what uh she and the couple have
been going through
this year saying that at the beginning
of the year she had
a miscarriage which she says left her
heart broken and while she feels
incredibly blessed
uh to be pregnant again she writes in
this post she's also felt like
a bag of nerves now this will be as i
say the second child that
carrie johnson and boris johnson have
had together they got married earlier
this year
in secret in the summer their first
child a son wilfred johnson was born
at the end of april last year in the
thick of the pandemic not long after
boris johnson got out of hospital out of
icu
himself now it's the second child for
carrie johnson
it will be the seventh child that boris
johnson
has had he has four children with his
previous wife marina wheeler who he
divorced
in 2018. he also has
another daughter um as the result of an
affair he had
but the second child for him uh and um
carrie johnson
and in this instagram post carrie
johnson uh put give some more details
um about why she felt the need to share
those details about the miscarriage she
had earlier this year she talks about
how fertility issues can affect many
people and can be
incredibly difficult given on platforms
like instagram
it often feels like uh people that are
having babies and that are pregnant
uh that everything uh is only ever going
well
she says and she says she found it a
real comfort to hear from people who had
also experienced loss
and hopes that in sharing what happened
to her that might in some
small way help so a second child
on the way for uh the prime minister and
his wife
and by the sounds of this instagram post
due at the end of this year